joining us right here on the Rich Eisen
share with a huge week 12 I had the
Super Bowl winning head coach for the
Ravens joining us here on the Rich Eisen
show how are you coach coach I'm doing
great rich you don't have to try to
impress me you just you open your mouth
and I'm constantly amazed now you know
what Brian
I appreciate that there may be an AI and
Brian and two and Billick but you're a
team player like that I appreciate that
thank you hey before before we start
down the road how was it to see your
name up in the the Ring of Honor
involved that's great
yeah I you know leading up to it I
didn't quite know what to expect you
know of course there's in the back your
mind your this fear that you come out
and you're and there's one guy sitting
in the stands that didn't go get his
nachos and beer and it's good yeah I
remember you but it was the most
gratifying thing was there were 65 of my
former players there they come back and
all and that that was really cool lot of
my had seen you obviously in years and
that just really made it really made it
special and obviously having your family
there right seeing grandpa's name up on
the stage oh yeah pretty much for Brecon
and Harry to be there and and and they
and and then doing Mike Guerra followed
it we did a bit in the pregame and and
my one grandson got on and so just to
see that and and you know they don't
know their pop in that regard they see
me on TV flapping my jaws but they don't
really know the other thing that was
that was really really special for them
to take all that in and and you know the
NFL 100 series that that's been running
the whole programming on NFL Network one
of the greatest teams of all time one of
the top 100 it was the the Vikings team
that you are the offensive coordinator
for as well I'm wondering how you view
that team despite the fact that there
wasn't even a Super Bowl appearance for
you and that well that right that's
where you normally see it when anybody
has a list of the greatest teams of all
time not to win a Super Bowl
thank you which is kind of painful to
look at because that was that was a
spectacular team particularly
offensively when you think of the talent
we had a Hall of Famer and Chris Carter
Hall of Famer and Randy Moss
Randall McDaniel John Randle phenom
Roberts
meant that running back Leroy hoard
obviously Randall Cunningham and
everything that he represented a
quarterback it was just a tacular Lee
talented team and and obviously the
affinity I have for Minneapolis and the
folks there with the Vikings too
to be so close and and and so capable of
winning a Super Bowl and still not
having one it's I know it's still
painful for them it's painful for me I
appreciate you bringing oh no I'm so
super hey but it's also being mentioned
is one of the greatest teams of all time
I mean it still it still it still
getting run like that right there though
yeah they're there they're you know and
breaking the all-time scoring records
for you know that was something that
that was that with us probably a
talented group offensively as we've seen
in this league let me start our football
conversation in the here and now from a
macro level Brian Billick here on the
Rich Eisen show we've got a team in New
England that's winning games on defense
I mean the in terms of defense point
nine touchdowns given up through ten
weeks they've given up fewer touchdowns
in games played then you look at the
Ravens and you look at San Francisco and
they both have over 2000 yards rushing
as a team how are we seeing a shift in
how to win football games especially
since it was week 12 last year that we
saw supposed death of defense between
the Rams and Chiefs Brian are we seeing
a shift here in the NFL yeah and then
had a Super Bowl that was what that was
was defensive dominated I don't know
that it's a shift you know that the
value or the perception of the value of
great defense or running the ball
certainly feel diminished when you talk
about the rule changes and the way
offenses are up and down the field and
the number of great quarterbacks we have
I don't know that it's a ship that even
with those at the end of the day you're
still going to need dynamic quarterback
play man I have to be for Hall of Fame
play but but you know you're you're
talking right now the three teams you
mentioned two of whom one's got a Hall
of Fame quarterback and Tom Brady the
other is a guy in Lamar Jackson that we
all just continually week after week on
playbook or costly talk I mean we could
every week talk about
Jackson and just how unique this guy is
I mean think about this Lamar Jackson in
his first 15 or 16 games I think I get
this right has rushed for more yards
than Lil Damien Thomlinson has thrown
more touchdown passes than Tom Brady and
has a higher completion percentage to
Drew Brees in their first 15 games that
that's that's you know it's like you
can't get that out of your mouth it just
like it's just not going to come out of
your mouth to say something which seems
of just ridiculous to say but back to
the point I still think we're going to
need that quarterback play when you look
at the Ravens and I think clearly
there's the best team right now they are
complete that's what makes them so scary
all but unique offense defense and
that's what's getting lost is how good
this defense is getting again because of
all the spectacular things that's going
on with with the offense and what
they're doing but this defense and
they're doing without a singular
dominant players they don't have the Ray
Louis they don't have Tyrell Suggs on
the back end you know they don't have
that agreed
they've just they're a very unbelievably
talented and solid defense that a you
can't run on them when they're healthy
and in that secondary they make it very
hard to get big play so of that group
that you're talking about and I think
that is the right group to talk about I
think Baltimore but it's an all the
people in the AFC the same way whether
it's Kansas City whether it's Houston
whether it's Baltimore can we go into
Foxborough because of you know knowing
lemon they're scheduling whatever could
very well end up with the number one
feet yeah I know that the only team that
does appear to have the ability to make
sure that Belichick and Brady pack a bag
in mid January to try and get to Miami
Baltimore is the only one that has that
chance because they've already beaten
him they're only a game behind they have
that time Eric but the question with
Lamar Jackson that constantly gets asked
Brian Billick here in the Rich Eisen
show is the question of sustainability
long-term for sure like long term how's
he going to look at will he be is banged
up as say Cam Newton is by the time he's
30 and then short term we saw what the
Chargers were able to do with Lamar
Jackson last year when he was just a
rookie and he got the reigns of an
offense that got changed in midstream in
the middle of last year
what about this year what you're seeing
through ten games the sustainability for
them to go to Miami when it all would be
what Brian well sustainability in terms
of what they're doing how its
schematically and tactically put
together the fact that they've had an
entire offseason and will now have an
entire season implemented compared to
last year where they kind of had to make
it up as you go absolutely they can
sustain it in their style of play I
think we've seen nothing to indicate
that Lamarr Jax is not going to continue
on I mean their formula is stunning
because of their ability to run the ball
and obviously with him being a huge part
of it they averaged 36 in their wins 36
or 37 minutes time of possession so you
know taking nothing away out great that
defense is it's easy to play pretty good
defense when you're not on the field but
and when they are on the field I think
you're really tough on offense is to not
go three now I mean Houston is a good
football team and and they just got beat
up all buddy in Baltimore mostly because
there's brilliant as deshaun Watson was
you get in you go three and out you're
dead
you don't see the ball again for a
quarter and a half that's a tough
combination so that can be sustained the
question of can Lamar Jackson stay
healthy you know and we're all waiting
for and not in a morbid way but going
Gees kind of guy he was carrying the
ball better 220 times on the year as a
quarterback can he do that not get hurt
and they've got a guy in RG 3 who's the
backup that I'm sure is sitting there
yeah not like the Grim Reaper but he's
you know kind of just going I've seen
this before I've seen this before be
careful you know that but they're all in
there buying all in and they don't care
they're gonna run him for as many times
as they got to run him and and he seems
to be able to kind of take care of
himself and you hope it keeps going
Brian Billick here on the Rich Eisen
show let's let's walk through the
marquee matchups then of this week
starting with tonight
the Texans and the Colts I like the
Colts Brian I love Quintin Nelson I
think he might be one of the most
valuable players that never gets
mentioned how he solidifies that line
and the run game and the past protection
the defense is getting better this seems
like the Colts have the Texans number I
wonder how you see Thursday night to
kick off week doesn't
yeah and how spectacular story is this
in terms of I mean weren't we all you
know Andrew Luck went down that's it for
in Indianapolis they're done I thought
that whole division going into the
season I'm gonna say it's the best but
it was going to be the most competitive
from top to bottom mainly because the
quarterback playing then we start season
and Boyd there's no Andrew Luck and then
Nick Foles goes down and now Marcus
Mariota is being replaced and yet it's
still staying competitive I Division let
alone obviously just what the culture
doing Jacobi per set and how about them
putting up better than 250 yards rushing
on the Jacksonville Jaguars so yeah I'm
at the cold but having said that I think
the Texans I think that offense and
notwithstanding what we saw against
Baltimore and the fact they're at home
it'd be great to see the tech of the
Colts come out and have that kind of
game just because they're a great
feel-good story forgot I kind of think
the Texans particularly after what they
had happened to them against Baltimore I
think this offense could be looking to
kind of break out so then let's move to
Sunday's marquee games starting with the
Patriots and the Cowboys I know it's
your favorite thing Brian the phrase
Bill Belichick always takes away the one
thing you do best
you love that because the rest of us
obviously did we obviously were covering
the decoys because it never cooked
occurred to us to take away what you do
best
it is going to be interesting because
yeah what does that mean that means you
got to stop to zico Elliot right I did a
bit on playbook talking about what you
talking about the number one offense and
the Cowboys and the more in defense in
New England and and the real interesting
ones they both lead the league
respectively in third down nobody plays
more man than the Patriots that ability
to put a five-man rush on dak Prescott
play man but yet the Cowboys are pretty
good at they do a nice job on the pick
routes and get Ezekiel out they got Cobb
Amari Cooper is number four in the
league among receivers versus man
coverage
so I think that that if you're looking
for one thing I would watch that third
down to see it now again going into Fox
for it so tough and here we're not even
talking about Tom Brady how about that
how does that tell you about the state
of the current New England Patriots but
I think the third down is going to be
the key and in Foxborough I think I
think Dallas may struggle on the third
down a little more than a half so you
would be identifying again because Bella
checks the only coach who does this
removing the one thing that you do best
you you would say 21 like he's sitting
in the meetings this defensive staff
saying that's the guy we're stopping not
19 in Cooper or four and Dec to try and
stop for you stop nineteen I mean so
yeah it's 21 do it and doing it
respectfully knowing that now they can
beat us the other way okay we recognize
that so we've got to take that into
account but following your Belichick Ian
process here absolutely
job one is if we get beat it's not going
to be because the zkl it's gonna go off
for 140 yards I'm not gonna let that
happen and the reason why we're not
talking Brady is because again it's the
defense has been so special but Brady I
mean usually what what what he has been
able to overcome are the receivers
needing nametags for the most part for
all of us in the country to know it
truly is just been a bunch of folks
- Edelman that he's not really used to
throwing - I know he had yet back in the
day Ben Watson and Phillip Dorsett has
been there for a hot minute the running
game has been absolutely eviscerated and
I'm wondering Isaiah win the left
tackles coming back if you think that
might help get a running game going that
that can be sustained in this contest
Brian yeah that's a hard day when we
talk about this with New England is and
I think you're exactly right it could
make a difference and typically you look
at team and you look at the numbers and
what they've done and say okay yeah boy
they just can't run the ball well well
with the Patriots you don't know because
a lot of times they're not even try
you know they're they're the most
chameleon offense in terms of one week
they may say ok we're going to run 45
times and do it and then the next week
go now we're not going to run ten times
because we
we can throw the ball and beat this
other team now that sounds like it's
making an excuse for the running game
because I agree with you the running
game probably hasn't been as good but a
lot of it with the Patriots it's now we
just know we're going to do this the
other way and we're better at that
the most striking thing to me about the
offense and it addresses what you're
talking about is right now if they stay
on par and obviously playing the great
defense that's number one thing
everybody's talking about they're saying
well is this gonna is this going to
break the Ravens you know all-time
scoring record and we broke the 85 Bears
all-time scoring record I'm kind of
going yeah hold on let's let's wait you
know cuz they're playing a little bit
better schedule now here the second half
of the season so we'll let's get a
little closer to it before we start you
know as Deion would say slow your roll
on that one a little bit I'm being a
little protective here but but back to
what I was saying is that Brady is on
par to be close to 650 throws which
tells you okay yeah we're not running
the ball real well but in that right now
he'd be on pace for the mid-20s 20 to 23
touchdowns to eight interception now
that's a good combination but for Tom
Brady you only throw 22 23 touchdown
passes that that's that's it's good news
bad news that's all we need the bad news
is you know maybe we're not being as
productive and good thing that the
defense is playing that well so well
we're gonna have to see if right get a
win back and if they if they decide to
play a couple of those games we're going
know we're gonna run the ball and see if
indeed they are still capable of it a
couple minutes I have left with Brian
Billick the other marquee event Sunday
and Monday night let's start with Sunday
night would you say it is fair to say or
would you go in a different direction
Green Bay at San Francisco is for the
right to call the the winner the best
team in the NFC through 12 weeks yeah I
think that's fair although I would say
this particularly when comes to the NFC
is top to bottom notwithstanding what
happens with Dallas and Philadelphia and
how that squad right now our field of
six is probably going to be who it is
again notwithstanding you know if if
Minnesota and Green Bay flop let's say
or even Seattle and San Francisco flock
I still think that's going to be
same group I don't think the Rams are
going to find their way into it and
Philadelphia Minds if they can rebound
in Dallas loses New England and whatever
but top to bottom I tell you what I
could be real convicted about any of
these teams ending up being in the Super
Bowl
clearly San Francisco if they win will
remain on top particularly with the win
at Green Bay it's usually beating Green
Bay of Green Bay could beat San
Francisco in San Francisco and Aaron
Rodgers is just being you know like I
said I didn't coin the phrase but I love
it
he's not the goat but he is the boat he
is the best of all time what he's doing
you talked about with a group of guys
that we don't know who they are
who knew who Aaron Jones was or kubrow I
mean we knew who Jimmy Graham was and
yet here he just keeps you know throwing
it out there and these guys keep you
know that they're there they're pretty
good offensively I think that's the
trouble also for San Francisco is going
to be those matchups defensively with
okay who do you put on Aaron Jones who
do you put on Jimmy Graham in that
secondary that Aaron Rodgers isn't going
to take advantage of it so yeah clearly
if Green Bay can go to San Francisco and
went on the road and and you know that
you gotta love it yes Aaron Rodgers
about home-field advantage what you want
it to be in Green Bay he goes well as
opposed to what go to San Francisco or
LA where it's 70°
and nice he goes I think I could live
with that too and then on Monday night
you just mentioned the Rams and their
prospects sitting there at 6 and 4 you
know to me there's so much conversation
about what's wrong with golf and and
then in terms of Girly's health and that
there there may be some merit to that
although the Rams have constantly been
saying he's fine it does appear to me
the issue there on offense is that line
that line was terrific last year it won
the the offensive line of the year
awarded NFL honors for a reason they
were together they were healthy this
year totally different that said it does
appear that they might have reconfigured
the line and found Gurley at the same
time against the Bears last week and
that might be a way for McVeigh to try
and kind of reverse a little bit
engineer what his offense has been and
go through that
certainly against a Ravens team that you
talked about dominating time of
possession I wonder if you think that
might be a key to victory for the Rams
on Monday night Oh it'll be a huge key
they're gonna have to do it they won't
because they're about to get their butts
handed to them because I say what this
Raven I'm not being a homer hear this
raven defend I did a bit on PlayBook
they're their interior when you talk
about Brandon Williams and Mikel Pierce
and they that attack Oh like they didn't
have enough beef in the middle they're
there they've got a defensive lineman
and Allen record that would be the
starter stud on most teams as an
interior defensive lineman and the only
way he's getting on the field is this
fullback I mean that's how deep they are
in the defensive line the secondary is
talented experienced the Rams and I
agree with you a hundred percent they're
going to challenge it they got a hope
they can run because otherwise the time
and possession it's going to be a long
day for them and and even if they are
better and they feel like they're back
on track I don't know that the Ravens
are going to be the team's try to prove
that we're really still back on track I
I think they're gonna have a tough tough
time running the ball Brian thanks the
time love the chat love it thanks for
the call we'll do it again sorry
right back at you that's Brian Billick
check out playbook on NFL Network every
single week for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on BR live or download
the Rich Eisen show app